okay so good morning and thank you for
the invitation everyone so I'm going to
talk about is something that we've been
doing so it's primarily the work of bill
Huggins who's here on investigating
actually just how expensive or what are
the costs for implementing quantum
chemistry calculations on the machines
that we have today and looking at what
are the bottlenecks and how one can
improve those so it's not really
addressing the issue of scale up or that
we are very concerned about analyzing
the resources and what I think we're
going to what we have learned from this
is sort of what is needed really to
simulate quantum chemistry on quantum
computers which would be relevant even
to the beyond disk era in terms of what
kind of circuits are involved and what
kind of measurements so background for
the talk is in these papers here you can
look at data part of it is a last part
of the talk will be a collaboration with
the Google Group and maybe Ryan might
also talk about that about measurements
but it's going to be basically come
focused on the variational quantum
algorithm and there'll be three topics
let me first of all just recap others
with shown also I think already several
times over the last couple of days this
is the idea of using variational
approach or evaluating quantum chemistry
the quantum chemistry problem is the
problem of calculating the ground state
and if possible also excited States or
molecular or material systems and this
is the electronic energies of ones of
interest of interest here and so so here
you have this scheme a schematic from
McClane and Brutus article in 2014 where
you have basically a quantum state
preparation which is a preferably a
shallow quantum circuit and this is then
put into a quantum
where there are measurements made and
the measurements will basically extract
all of the different components or
expectation values what are the
different components of the electronic
Hamiltonian and these are then put sent
into a the measurements of these
expectation values are sent into a
classical processor which puts them all
together in the right form to extract
the total expectation value of the
electronic Hamiltonian and then there's
a classical optimization procedure which
will optimize the parameters in the
quantum state in the circuits for the
quantum state preparation so this is
this is an an iterative procedure and if
you look at what's really quantum here
is the state preparation is quantum the
measurement in a sense is is it's also a
quantum measurement and but that's
associated then with noise post the
intrinsic noise from the quantum
measurement and also the noise of
implementation and then also the
classical so then this part from Briand
here is classical where one takes this
noisy data and attempts to do a
classical optimization so a stochastic
optimization over this to improve the
guess of the wave function or the the
understood ones preparing here and to go
around again so so the basic question is
will such will investing effort in such
variational implementing such
variational algorithms on the NIST
devices available today where we don't
have any error correction and we have a
considerable amount of intrinsic noise
in the device it will it be useful for
chemistry so yeah so our view is that
not without a considerable amount of
further development but let me make a
comment before going on that actually if
you turn the question around will
question be will full chemistry or
chemical kinds of problems be useful for
this devices I think actually with a
billion that maybe I'll make some more
comments at the end of the talk but
these devices are actually quite useful
to understand and characterize where the
noise comes from and maybe we can you
also to make more more flexible error
mitigation protocols and even quantum
error correcting codes okay but so here
so let me continue now with the
challenges that we we have looked at in
terms of implementing these misc
variation algorithms so in first one is
that if you have a small noisy device
you really don't can't use deep circuit
because of restricted coherence times
and also so it's coherence times of the
qubits as well as the fidelity of the
gate and secondly when it requires a
very large number of repeater circuit by
evaluations and this is because you're
on the one hand you need repeated
circuit evaluations for making
measurements quantum measurements and
then secondly to do the optimization so
these reflect two different kinds of
limitations on the run time of
algorithms firstly the coherence time
which limits the quantum part and
secondly basically the total time which
includes that and many other things and
which is a generic which can vary from
one algorithm to another but in our case
includes time for a measurement time for
the classical processing and so there's
these kind of lit this small time
limitation will be a limitation on any
kind of hybrid algorithm so firstly in
detail the coherence a time limitation
so this is really due to the limited
coherence times of the qubits that we
currently have in devices in the
real-time devices and these implosives
poses sort of a hard upper limit on how
long single computation will take so it
limits the time of the circuits that you
can that you use to generate your
initial States and so you might think
that we can take a just pretty arbitrary
unstructured initial state but part of
what makes actually doing quantum
chemistry on these quantum computers
interesting is the the initial states or
the actual the actual eigenstates of
electronic states of molecules are
actually very highly structured which is
partly due to the strong Coulomb
interaction but it's also due to the
thermionic statistics of the electrons
this high structure means that if you
start with a very unstructured initial
state you really don't get anywhere so
you actually really care about
generating and intelligent anzats to put
in and to try to then have a shallower
circuit as possible to good and that so
then in addition we have the noisy
nature of the the quantum gate and so so
to estimate to make us a rough estimate
of the costs due to coheres time we'll
take just the total number of the two
qubit gates
so if we think about total time I'm not
sure the complexities all right where
it's used for this but in terms of sort
of the scaling of the total time
resources it's different kind of
complexity like Garnett would look
designing various kinds of complexity
earlier so we have then many we have to
execute a very large number of circuits
we want these with these circuits have
to be simple because we don't have large
deep circuits capability so and putting
that all together with the number of
circuits you need for optimization and
for measurement can lead to very large
amounts of time so in addition one has
so if you're actually doing this over a
large amount of time that you'll have
calibration drift and other time
dependent errors in your device so which
also then put you know Pro device
specific limitations on the time window
so if we just take the number of circuit
repetitions the measure of the cost
that's a reasonable then second measure
to contrast with the coherent time
complexity so what we want to do is to
reduce we also put a reduces cost and
secondly we want to enable trade-offs
between them if we have
we want to enable trade-offs between
them and so here's a couple that we've
looked at so one is we can reduce a
number of two qubit gates required in
the state preparation by design of new
or certainly have improved and that's of
electronic States and I'll tell you a
little bit about that and then secondly
we can trade the total number of two
qubit gates for most circuit repetitions
and I'll show you how that works and
that's done by using a linear
combination of ANZAC States and forming
a generalized eigenvalue problem rather
than solving the the eigenvalue solving
a single with a single and that's
variational e and lastly we can reduce
the number of required circuit
repetitions by clever choice of the
measurement basis the basis in which we
make measurements and I'll show you a
little bit about that as well okay so
the the objets that we we look at and I
think a lot of people look at in this
field now is unitary couple cluster so
couple cluster is a well-known way to
introduce correlations into electronic
wave functions yeah okay so you
basically take something which would be
a mean field type of wave function fee
on the right that's what's referred to
as a hartree-fock solution and then one
operates on it with a an exponential
operator which introduces correlations
between electrons in different single
particle orbitals and in quantum
chemistry so very well-known technique
is using excitations which just consists
of single particle excitations and two
particle excitations out of this mean
field description and what's shown here
so these a x' a Tigers and AIDS are the
creation and annihilation of praise for
the fermions and they can translate you
can think of this as these translate
with the transformation the Jordan
vignette transformation to the power
operators on the spins and you can think
if you think of one
in the simplest representation one cubit
represents one occupied or unoccupied
there are two possible states of the
qubits represent one electron a
one-electron orbital which can be either
occupied or not occupied okay so those
the operator a will remove an electron
from the state so that's like a lowering
operator and the electric the operator a
dagger will add an electron to that
state so it will act like a raising
operator it's been operated so so these
terms here basically are just moving
around the electrons between the
different orbitals and if you do this
because of the exponential nature of
this these correlations are you're
introducing you get an order and six
scaling classically in terms of the
number of spin orbitals and the orbitals
are so called spin orbitals because they
involve both the spatial location of the
electron and also the spin degree of
freedom so each spatial orbital can have
two spin States so that makes two spin
orbitals so this is actually a challenge
for dealing with more than small systems
and it's also particularly ones
interested in systems where you do have
strong correlations between the
electrons and so then it's it's it's
really that's what this would introduce
to do but it's hard to do and secondly
this is not a unitary operator here and
the result of that is that the classical
approach was that operator doesn't
evaluate the energy variation Li so
instead one prefers to use a unit couple
cluster but this scales exponentially
it's even worse it wasn't used much in
quantum chemistry but now that we're
thinking about quantum computers people
are thinking about this more so if you
look at the way this if you were to
expand this so it for instance with
cauterization you'd get an N cubed
scaling for circuit depths for one
Trotter step which is a lot better than
exponential and also you have the
advantage that the unit recap of cluster
is variational apart from the
statistical errors
so what we'd like to do is to develop
underseas which have which we improve
beyond this Ncube and let me actually
just show what would that how this
really works for a sample case for
instance h4 which is a very simple
benchmark type of molecular it's not a
molecule that people make in the lab but
it's just four hydrogen atoms so it's
four electrons one on each of the
hydrogen atoms they can be arranged in
different kinds of geometries and you
can solve this problem exactly so it's a
good benchmark case that people have
used for many years to study it also has
a lot of strong a lot of different
extents of correlation depending on the
geometry so also it's been used for
quite a long time to test test message
for strong correlations and so if one
takes the common approach where when you
just see single and double operators and
you look at the the amount of work you
have to do for this h4 in a minimal
basis basically one that one electron
orbital per hydrogen atom then you get
twenty amplitude orbitals and they're
simple simple implementation of one
trotter step for this and that's will
require a two or four qubit unitary for
each of these cluster amplitudes that
you want to add and then some additional
overhead depending on their connectivity
of your device so if you
you use generalized excitations then the
number scales as entered before so this
is still pretty high and so what we have
done is we've proposed a simpler well as
a system which is in a sense more
introduces a different structure but
results in with the same kind of I'll
show you some results it shows you the
same kind of accuracy but it has only
order KN squared
amplitude so you get a significant
reduction in the number of gates that
you need to implement so what we do here
is we just restrict ourselves to the
exit these excitation operators which
move pairs of electrons between spatial
orbitals rather than individual
electrons moving and restricted and then
we to make up for that restriction we
then consider each operator the entire
operator and then multiply it k4 times
two so this means that we're introducing
extra gates here which will be all of
the same form but then the
parameterization in the optimization
there'll be separate parameters for each
of these cluster operators then we can
implement this efficiently using
thermionic swap gates or the brain
O'Gorman in my group are developed and
other people have those various flavors
of these you can then reorder the modes
of the system to efficiently implement a
Trotter step here and you can actually
invert it now in order K n depth using
KN squared gates so this is kind of
detail I'll show you a figure on the
next slide so we have here as this
example for this is this simple h4 then
you can basically in this minimal basis
you can have a circuit with 536 two
qubit gates which might be achievable in
the in the not-too-distant future so
here's here's what this one one block of
this K K fold couple cluster circuit
looks like so it's here you see all
these swap gates in between these two
qubit gates and then the
long blocks here are the four cubic
gates and this is a generic four cubed
term here this is not any one specific
from that particular calculation but if
you were to be moving this wouldn't be
an unrestricted operator where you're
operating on four if you so if these a
one eight if one two three and four or
four different orbitals so this would be
an unrestricted form but in practice we
take restricted operations in this
particular implementation in the K UPC
CD so here this would be a sample for
qubit gate that we'd have to include
some double controlled swap gates and
that would go in here so that's sort of
what's involved and then if you so then
we've made calculations to see how well
this would actually do in terms of the
accuracy so as I mentioned so chemists
can never measure the absolute energies
and so typically one is interested in
the getting an accuracy to within what
can be measured and that's of the order
of 10 to the minus 3 atomic units Isana
garnet mentioned that's in these units
those are these milli Hartree units here
so that's what these energies are in and
so what's shown here is this is now for
the nitrogen molecule so it's somewhat
more challenging than this hydrogen
complex the nitrogen molecule has three
double three bonds so it's a so-called
triple bond and this is a very strongly
correlated molecule and it's also a
canonical sort of test case for
electronic structure methods so what
we've done here is a sixteen qubit vqe
simulation on a classical computer for a
range of different distances of the
nitrogen molecule bond distances so this
is now this is now simply this molecule
here
and we're looking at this typical kind
of diagram where as a function of the
distance
between two nuclei we calculate the
electronic energy and the ground state
electronic energy and this is the bound
molecules so we denote this by three
lines here to indicate that there's six
electrons making up this bond so what
with MC is that so in this case each
case we have to then optimize the
cluster amplitudes to get the strong
correlation in there and so if you start
off over here there are these are the
classical methods this isn't these
columns here are the unitary couple
cluster approaches and so we see if we
have one block then we have add multiple
blocks here going along here we get
successively lower energies here and
here you see that these oh sorry these
are the errors yeah so they and these
are the errors above the exact value
which CI for configuration interaction
and you see here that these two blocks
in green are within this chemical
accuracy requirement for something that
would actually cause a quantum chemist
to actually look at look at it and more
than twenty seconds and so this is with
five levels or six levels six blocks of
the correlations so this is quite nice
it's not such an extensive overhead
that's one thing one can do is basically
to take a classical and rats use tools
from classical quantum chemistry that
adapt them to the quantum regime and try
to do as much work as you can in pre-pro
so classical pre-processing eventually
to generate then a an accurate but at
the same time relatively shallow a
quantum circuit to a state preparation
second thing that one can do is trading
two qubit gates for circuit repetitions
and this is basically making taking the
variational quantum approach and
replacing this by a
a generalized eigenvalue equation which
is actually an analogue of what's done
in classical quantum mechanics to
basically instead of taking one
understates you expand in a basis and
then the task is to find the coefficient
cm in the basis this is a standard a
minimization then R in a basis set and
then so the M is one here would be
regular vqe if we have M greater than 1
when we minimize this we then get a
generalized eigenvalue equation and so
the idea of this approach is that we
would use the quantum computer to
evaluate all of the matrix elements that
are required for this generalized
eigenvalue equation and that would be
then solved with a classical processor
and for many under states that this is
actually quite attractive because
measuring these off diagonal matrix
elements can be done using the exact
same circuits that you are used for the
state preparation together with just a
constant number of control to up gates
and very small cost for coupling to
announce illa so this cost itself then
for measuring these off diagonal
elements is independent of the number of
basis States in your and that in the in
the linear combination and so therefore
you can use this flexibility that you
get by increasing over having more than
one basis state to increase the
representational power of the state and
given parameters the parameters now over
are increased over 2m but without
requiring more coherent resources
because you're basically using exactly
or not exactly but of almost the same
amount of quantum gates to generate all
of these matrix elements and then do the
classical processing the disadvantage is
however that we've now got to measure
many more matrix elements and this
requires more overall circuit
evaluations so your circuits are not as
deep but you have to have many more
repetitions of them
you hear some results for okay so this
is another molecule this is
this is cycling this is not this is a
hexa train that sex I mean six one two
three so this is the molecule that has
these are carbon atoms and then there's
hydrogen's here
so this has got these are double bonds
so they here that's poor electrons and
so this is a conjugated molecule the
electrons are actually delocalized over
these entire set of bonds right and
what's shown here is the result of doing
a vqe type calculation so an example
what we call this now Nov QE
non-orthogonal vqe because the important
point here is that these states do not
need to be orthogonal they could be but
these basis space don't need to be and
from greatest generality we we don't
allow with require them to be lava no
that means we have to also evaluate the
overlap matrix elements and we call it
non orthogonal vqe and what's shown here
is the error in the ground state energy
for calculations with twelve qubits
representing six PI orbitals and there
under spin partners of these as a
function of the number of basis states
in the nav QE expansion and the number
of blocks in the unitary couple cluster
representation of each one of those
functions and it's shown here for two
different versions of this molecule so
the equilibrium version is this where
these are all nicely like this in this
is planar and then if you twist around
this central bond here you get something
with its non planar and that's highly
strained the twisted one and that's what
the twisted geometry is shown here so
let me just but they show that these
results show the same behavior so I'll
just focus on this so what we see is
that okay so first of all what's
familiar here with M is one that's
basically vqe so you see here then ab
we're increasing K this is K is one this
is going down to increasing K so as you
increase K as I showed you before you
increase the flexibility of the wave
function answers and you get better
results
larger values of gay but of course as
you're going down this axis you're
increasing the number of gates in your
state preparation circuit if you now go
to an obituary and use more than one
basis function with more correspondingly
more parameters now you're coming along
this axis you see the for a given value
of K the energy will also go down nicely
as you increase M so you greater
flexibility from the Nov QE approach of
adding more basis functions what's it is
nice here you see the trade-off emerges
here that if you look at the Nov QE
calculations of K is 1 so you're
basically keeping just one block on the
unitary couple clustered a
representation but you're increasing the
number of basis state you will rapidly
go down here and you'll go down below
the chemical accuracy threshold here
you'll have more the point is that you
will then have fewer two qubit gates
here so number of two qubit gates
basically increases from up here but
then it basically stays constant and so
as you're going down this line for
instance its line you have K is 2 and K
is 2 should have greater flexibility in
the form of the wave function and it has
lower and it gets lower energies here
but if you go back to the K is 1 the
simple couple class of form but you
increase instead the number of basis
states you'll find that with essentially
no more overhead than in with just
increasing number of basis states but
not increasing the number of gates here
that you can then with you can get also
to the same level of accuracy so
basically what you see is that by going
to increasing the number of basis states
that you can do calculations with fewer
two qubit gates for the same amount of
chemical accuracy then if you were to
just stay at the BQE level and increase
the number of gates
those are the Arabic come from from the
measurements the merriment of each
project yeah yeah because now you're
measuring also if you're measuring also
the you're measuring the overlaps and
errors and them overlaps are good
because you have to I mean a bad sorry
because that's the question for bill you
mention what's a psalm fault I mean this
is they were sampled from a Gaussian
distribution and I don't know what it
was for that that you're actually
reading what this statistical noise for
measurement and those are just those
points are different realizations of
doing the whole training with some some
randomness and the optimization so that
the optimization stochastic is somewhat
challenging and if you start with
different initial frame matter with you
and death bit slightly different
solutions and so we just did a few of
them and showed the media
and then the last thing is this is just
to say what two sides or I can find are
you going to talk about what some okay
let me just say what about this then
okay so in terms of measuring so you
have a large number of terms in this
electronic Hamiltonian you have to
measure and standard approach to doing
this it says okay so we write the
Hamiltonian as we do the fermionic to
spin transformation so we write it then
as a sum of power Li terms and then you
look at the terms and you see that if
two if two terms have if only they're
all the single qubit measurements agree
on each qubit as in these ones here
these two in the middle you can measure
those terms but you can't measure them
if they don't if the two middle qubits
here this is it Z Z and X X so you can't
measure these in the one common basis
you would have to first do a rotation so
the general the general procedure is to
group all the terms into simultaneously
measurable sets which results in a order
n to the four different groups but the
alternative strategy one alternative
strategy is if you first rotate the
single particle basis States here with
an operator u you can then make a
factorization which will reduce the
number of circuit repetitions required
for measurement and in particular you
can go you can actually get a very
dramatic decrease from order n to the
four to order n so I think I think we're
running out of time I won't give you
more details there's some results here
which show this works quite nicely so I
think then you can look at the paper or
come talk to us to see how it works in
detail let me just summarize so really
that we've been looking at the order
identify two different different kinds
of constraints on this calculation
specific and this is anything some of
this is specific to the quantum
chemistry problem so those constraints
are the number of two qubit gates which
can be formed which are limited by the
actual coherence time of the qubits and
the number of overall circuit
evaluations which are limited by
several factors into clearly if you're
doing a variational approach you're
going to have both measurement
repetitions for measurement and
repetitions for the optimization and
then we've shown that there are several
strategies I think there are many more
strategies that can be developed to
reduce the cost of the certainty of
applying quantum chemistry and to enable
trade-offs I think what's interesting
may be for the future is to look at
trade-offs between the different kinds
of costs Oakland has and so that's what
that let me close and thank you for
attention I'm here non-orthogonal think
Hughie's so the results for the Kate was
one where you you know we're able to get
below chemical accuracy with the viewer
see knots how did you do the honor is a
ssin of the state preparation on sod
spinner that varies wildly depending on
how you order those those operators you
know I mean do you have a strategy for
Tuesday that K equals one seems to be
very sensitive whereas if you increase
it it that so when you increase it then
you've got more blocks so it even K as
one you've got a lot of terms inside the
K is one that's why you have a large set
of gates so if you increase the number
of blocks then in a sense you're
increasing the dimensionality of your
parameter space and you have many more
solutions and sometimes in this case it
seems to be easier to find solution yeah
the cable to gets easier I have a
strategy for for yet for doing choosing
those ordering dessert
we just used simple we haven't really
worked too much on you reducing it right
it was just simple Trotter which gives
at least minimal circuit
yeah yeah
about the unitary rotation to reduce the
measurement costs to the single
excitation measurement do you see that
there's a change to the variance of the
measurement variance by reducing when
you group the poly sweater there's
there's a change to the overall variant
but even though you're sampling less the
variance seems to still decrease in the
measurement you know if you have you
looked at whether the variance is the
same or if it changes when you reduce
the number of measurements by doing that
unitary rotation scaling right up there
area yeah I think wonder that paper for
the different strategies we compared
them mainly by looking at the variance
with respect to the ground state of the
different groupings and it you get some
advantage even when you look at that
more realistic cops model it it
decreases quite a bit depending on how
you group them and it just seems
especially helpful to to do this fitting
in the different single particle basis
[Applause]